i went to vietnam with joe dimaggio
right
and i actually gave him a shower one
night in the middle of the jungle
you gave him a shot joe dimaggio well
the only way it happened were
we got men tell the story sure go ahead
okay
you know we we went from uh san
francisco to vietnam
me joe jerry coleman tony conigliero
wow and they broke us up into two groups
and joe and i went south and the other
two went north and we ended up meeting
them on the
uh intrepid which is docked down here
right
and we're out in the middle of the
jungle and it's so damn hot you can't
sleep
joe says i got to take a shower i said
joe we're not downtown saigon this is
the middle of the jungle
so the only way you can take a shower is
they have like a bamboo thing
and somebody's got to get up on a chair
and pour the water in and pull a string
and onto somebody and joe's taking a
shower right now
the best way to describe joe dimaggio is
he's a penis with a man hanging from it
right that's huge right you know how
easy when we were kids they called them
shower shoes they called thongs did they
joe wore three of them oh wow
this penis was that huge oh my god it
was legendary right
with the man hanging from it was
unbelievable how many inches would you
say joe dimaggio well he said that ain't
where it ends that's where it bends
no he's kidding down to his knees oh my
god
so you had to bathe this man this is not
just
the water
did you say is that the biggest i got to
be the only guy in the world to give joe
dimaggio a shower yeah was that the
biggest one you've ever seen i mean
you've been in locker rooms all over the
world
yeah yeah he was a did you say he was
quite a man
did you say joe my god jesus i tried if
i had a camera phone i took a picture
on